[Music]
hello today we'll be discussing how to
build a 2 foot tall 4x4 raised bed the
same principles for making this bed can
be used for making raised beds of other
sizes such as 6 by 6 or 4 by 8 the first
step is gathering all the proper
materials there are many types of
materials you can use for building a
raised bed such as wood cinder blocks or
bricks for the structure we will be
building today we have chosen to use
untreated Douglas fir because it is
relatively inexpensive and can last for
many years before showing signs of rot
other useful wood types for building a
raised bed are cedar juniper or
reclaimed wood that has not been treated
we will be building our raised bed two
feet high to make tending to the bed
easy from a seated position if this does
not concern you one foot is plenty high
for a raised bed so in order to build
our structure we have gathered a box of
three inch deck screws or brackets for
reinforcement
a box of finishing washers a cordless
drill for 8 foot 2 by 12 boards and one
8 foot 4x4 if you buy wood from your
local wood supplier or big-box store
they will cut the wood for you you get
started plan read like your raised bed
to go make sure you place it in a spot
that has an even surface and receives
full Sun which is about 8 hours per day
it can be helpful to pre-drill holes so
that the screws go in properly and
easily begin assembling the raised bed
by fastening together two boards the
boards should be flushed together when
building a raised bed it can be very
helpful to have assistants holding the
boards in place we suggest either having
a partner to assist you or a couple of
cinder blocks to hold the board steady
use two screws to fasten the boards
together and repeat this until the first
frame is complete
add the four by fours to each corner
attach the second frame one board at a
time screw the boards to the four by
fours and then to each other
do this until the frame is complete for
even more reinforcement you can add a
bracket to each corner now that the bed
is built fill the inside with cardboard
this will help prevent weeds and will
eventually decompose and become worm
food fill the structure with a gardening
soil and compost blood thank you for
watching this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu